I haven't made a reservation, but
please take a seat now.
I can't let people know that there's a connection
Umm,
I heard you're doing something,
can I ask you for a love consultation?
I have an acquaintance, yay,
don't say anything unnecessary, Miki-chan, what kind of
girl is the
other person
?
Maybe you're thinking of giving spikes as a gift because it's a club, but if
it's too expensive, your impression of monetary value will take precedence over your feelings, and
if this is the case, first of all, friendships are the first
[music].
I don't think you need to be hasty and rush to confess
.
Oh, I see, I really want to talk to you about aphrodisiacs What happened just
now, so we get together on the way home from cram school, etc.
Should I confess?
There is no doubt that the other party is interested in you if you hear the feeling.If
you confess it, the order hack should go
well.It's over.I understand.Thank
you.